Is a potentially-repeatable recursion source
like Evolution Witness a card draw spell? How
about something that draws and discards like
Matzalantli, the Great Door, is that considered
a draw spell? What about so-called impulse
draw options like Laelia, the Blade Reforged?
I imagine you might have opinions on any one
of these questions. Maybe you said yes to all,
maybe you said yes to none, and maybe you’re
a diehard Great Door fan, no more no less.
It would be satisfying and lovely if I could just
flat out say exactly what does and does not count
as card draw among these, but unfortunately it’s
a bit more complicated than that. Fundamentally,
the source of the ambiguity here is that card
draw as a concept often gets treated as one
singular thing, but it’s actually more like a
web of overlapping solutions to a handful of
different goals, and different decks will want the
sorts of things deemed “card draw” for completely
different reasons. The goals of card draw are a
little fuzzy, but broadly there are two main ones
that most decks will be focused on: spending
excess mana, and finding particular cards.
Let’s start with the first one. That word
“excess” actually might be a bit misleading,
because for the sorts of decks that will most
want to think about their card draw this way,
getting excess mana is often a large point
of the deck. The most obvious deck style
that fits within this description would be
battlecruiser midrange, a type of deck that
is typically lategame-focused and involves lots
of ramp. My Radha deck is an example of this,
and it’s a good style of deck to build for players
newer to the commander format because it follows a
simple principle—spending more mana than opponents
will generally make it easier to defeat them,
regardless of what else is happening. In
this framework, this requires two simple
steps—obtain a larger total pool of resources
through ramp, and then figure out a way to
spend those resources in a way that is supporting
what your deck is trying to do. This is actually
pretty similar to the process of learning a Real
Time Strategy game—becoming an average-skill
Starcraft player basically just requires
two things: building up resource generation,
and then being able to spend all of the
resources you end up accumulating. We can
see parallels to EDH battlecruiser decks with
this—as long as you’re completing the basic
tasks like hitting land drops, playing some ramp
spells, and spending all of your mana each turn,
you’ll probably be having an okay time,
and once you’re at that point you can
turn your attention to the specifics of
what tasks your mana is accomplishing.
In the context of this type of deck, a deck
chiefly concerned with managing mana gained vs
mana spent, all sorts of things can loosely fit
into the category of draw. Adding X-spells to a
deck will typically reduce its need for draw,
since they’re very effective at spending mana,
and the same goes for X-abilities and other
abilities that are useful to sink a lot of
mana into over a turn cycle. These aren’t exactly
draw, and you’d get some weird looks if you tried
to call them that, but they absolutely perform
some of the same functions as draw in decks
mostly focused on spending mana. The key here is
going to be making sure that mana is spent in ways
that are actually effective at pushing toward
a deck’s goals. Throwing a random Fireball in
an Isshin deck might make it better at spending
mana, but an X-cost damage spell probably isn’t
a type of the card that will generally progress a
creature-based midrange deck. The best available
ways to spend mana will typically be creatures
with on-attack draw abilities that synergize
with the deck’s commander, and there are also
a number of utility lands in Mardu colors
that can soak up mana while accomplishing
useful tasks for a combat-centered deck.
Maybe you scoffed at the idea that a mana-sink
spell or ability could be considered alongside
draw, and for a lot of decks, that’s an entirely
valid impulse. Some decks want an ongoing flow of
actual factual cards they can play, whether that
be answers or utility creatures or anything else,
and that brings me to a couple draw alternatives
that still lean in the direction of spending mana.
The first is cards that exile cards and allow
you to play them for the next turn or two,
with these effects sometimes being called “impulse
draw”. These don’t allow having cards stick around
until a potential future point where they’re
useful, so they’re best utilized in decks with
few situational cards and more general purpose
cards that the deck will rarely feel bad about
casting. Another popular non-draw source of value
generation is recursion spells, cards that return
things from graveyard to hand. This could be
a big one-time option such as Seasons Past,
and it could also be a recursion engine such as
Evolution Witness plus counter shenanigans, Scrap
Trawler plus some artifacts, or even something
discrete like Phyrexian Reclamation. You could
even include graveyard abilities such as flashback
or escape in this category. All of these options
serve a similar task—allowing already-played cards
to be reused again. These sorts of effects are
typically going to be strongest in decks that
involve lots of redundancy and similar cards,
since returning a common card type from graveyard
to hand is going to be pretty similar in effect to
drawing one of those cards. However, these still
tend to have limitations, in that they require
having stuff in the graveyard to function.
For a deck with lots of sacrifice or which is
based around instants and sorceries, key cards
will get into the graveyard all on their own,
but other types of decks might want sources of
self-mill or self-discard to keep their graveyard
stocked with juicy options for returning.
Generally the more self-mill or wheel-style
effects you add to a deck, the more your recursion
spells will stray away from the task of spending
mana and start to gain some genuine card selection
potential, and this brings me to the second goal.
The second goal of so-called draw is finding
particular cards you need, and this goal tends
to be served by cards that might be considered
“filtering”. Cards that draw and discard, or
otherwise filter through cards without obtaining
card advantage, are going to be better and better
the more a deck cares about specific cards.
The most obvious case is in something like a
combo piece, but the same could go for a deck that
has five prominent centerpiece synergy cards that
it would like to find one or more of. On a more
abstract level, filtering will have the greatest
utility in decks with a high degree of variation
between cards, or variance between different power
levels. Seeing three different variants of a
low-cost beater with a filtering spell like Dig
Through Time isn’t getting a whole lot of usage
out of the card, while seeing a bunch of wildly
different cards is much more potent. Likewise,
if you’re casting Impulse, seeing four different
cards of roughly the same power level is, on some
level, getting less use out of the card than if
you instead saw three filler cards and a powerful
centerpiece. If we want to stretch the definition
of filtering a little, and I certainly do, tutors
are the ultimate example of this—cards that search
a player’s library for a card that fits some set
of constraints. Solve the Equation is basically
a Silundi Vision that looks at unlimited cards
instead of 6, and Demonic Tutor is basically an
Impulse that looks at unlimited cards instead of
4. Sorcery speed, though, so it’s pretty balanced.
So, do tutors count as card draw? Do cards like
Impulse count as draw? It depends on what your
deck’s goals are with running these cards. In some
decks it might be important to distinguish between
what cards give card advantage as opposed to what
cards only give card selection. A spellslinger
deck might run Impulse, and it might be a helpful
card for smoothing out gameplay, but if the deck
is currently running a fairly low number of
draw engines, it’s not necessarily going to be
a helpful addition for purposes of maintaining
cards in hand. Likewise, if you have a really
impactful card you’re tutoring for, a tutor very
well could feel like a draw spell, particularly
if it’s a tutor that generally searches up some
sort of value engine. A Steelshaper’s Gift that
exclusively finds Skullclamp followed by Sword
of Forge and Frontier? That’s a draw spell,
get it out of that tutor category. In other cases,
though, a tutor won’t make sense to think of as
draw. When I’m deckbuilding on Archidekt, I’ll
generally put tutors in my draw category in two
cases: if they generally find a source of card
advantage, or if the function of tutors wholly
lines up with the function of drawing cards. For
example, if I’m playing a combo deck where the
main thing my draw spells accomplish is digging
for combo pieces or tutors, then the purpose of
my draw is almost exclusively card selection, and
tutors accomplish that. I’ve also reached the same
conclusion in the opposite direction—my Breena
deck is an aggro deck with lots of redundancy,
so tutors aren’t much better than basic card draw.
When I added Ayara’s Oathsworn because of its
synergy with the commander, there was no reason
for me not to group it with the deck’s draw,
because it’s performing the same task. However,
in other decks, tutors play a somewhat distinct
role. In my strongest deck, I run tutors to find
Time Sieve because that’s what I need to win,
but I also run Bident of Thassa effects which
generically draw cards when my creatures hit
players. This can help find Time Sieve, but
it can also draw me into counterspells to
protect my combo, and if Time Sieve is up
and running but I don’t have a full combo,
having an engine that gives me an extra 3-4
cards a turn is typically enough to turn a
couple extra turns into a win by helping me
find things to give extra artifacts. Card
selection and card advantage are both helpful,
and having a mixture of selection-only cards and
generic card draw that provides both works out to
fulfill the deck’s needs in the draw department.
We can actually construct a spectrum and place
all the types of cards I’ve mentioned today on it.
On one side, we have pure selection—effects that
are all about seeing extra cards—and on the other
side, pure advantage—cards that turn mana into
value without seeing any cards at all. Ledger
Shredder? Pure filtering. Tutors? Generally
also pure filtering, though a bit flexible
depending on what you play to get. Cards like
Dig Through Time still lean toward filtering,
though at least here you’re getting some actual
factual card advantage as well by being one card
that finds two cards. I’d also put Greater
Good here, a powerful green draw enchantment
that tends to churn through cards at a fast
rate. Nearing the center of this spectrum,
you’ve got things that generate a decent bit of
card advantage but also do a bit of extra digging,
and this includes my personal favorite draw-X
card in most decks, Pull from Tomorrow. It’s
instant speed, reasonably costed, and
the disadvantage of discarding a card
is typically negligible since it’s attached
to a card that draws a bunch of cards first.
You could also put something like Necropotence
here, since absent a Reliquary Tower you’ll
generally be exiling some amount of what you
draw even if there’s a lot of volume of cards
entering your hand. Generic card draw leans a bit
toward advantage as compared to other options,
though a lot of the strongest draw is just generic
card draw, so oftentimes decks will focus on this
even if they mostly care about card selection.
After that you’ve got impulse draw and recursion
engines, and while the former is relatively
straightforward, the latter will vary a bit
depending on how much it’s supported. Recursion
spells might lean very close to advantage,
though they also might have some degree of
selection as well depending on how much self-mill
and discard a deck has. It’s often far easier
to get cards into the graveyard than into hand,
but the tools for hating on graveyards are far
stronger and far more ubiquitous than cards that
force opponents to discard are, so recursion has
some natural limits in how reliable it can be. On
the far end of things we have abilities that can
soak up an unlimited amount of mana. Kessig Wolf
Run is a land with a powerful activated ability
that a deck can sink as much mana as they like
into. It will never find you any cards, but it can
grant the value of giving a creature you control
+X/+0 and trample, and the only cost to have this
ability available is running a colorless land.
So this is a spectrum of what different styles
of draw and filtering will accomplish in terms
of value and card selection, but I worry that
all this categorization and visual flourish
and such like might serve to abstract the
issue beyond what’s helpful. So, how do you
find the best options for your deck, and how do
you know when you have enough? Let’s start with
that first question. Broadly, what types of value
generation and filtering you’ll want will depend
on your gameplan, your colors, and what sorts
of stuff your deck is made up of. Generally,
the more variation that exists between your
different cards, the more you’ll want to focus on
filtering. If you have lots of situational cards,
or a handful of specific cards you want to find,
you’ll want to lean toward cards that allow
you to see more of your deck. Look for options
closer to the right end of the spectrum
I gave earlier—tutors, draw and discard,
topdeck manipulating cards, and so on. Notably,
it’s generally pretty rare that a deck will want
exclusively card selection, so your task will
be in figuring out what amount and what forms of
actual draw you want to pair with your filtering.
In some cases, selection and advantage options
will mesh together quite nicely—recursion and
abilities that can be used from the graveyard
work great as an advantage source to pair
with card selection in the form of draw and
discard—the selection feeds advantage options that
might be a bit mediocre on their own. Likewise,
running tutors to find a centerpiece draw
engine is another popular way to combine a
selection option with an advantage option. For a
third, somewhat more specific example, sometimes
you’ll have creatures that do some sort of topdeck
filtering on an attack or combat damage trigger,
and pairing these with Curiosity-style effects
can set you up quite well for a second main phase.
On the opposite end of things, decks that lean
toward advantage as the preferred card type
typically include more redundancy—put simply,
you don’t need to spend nearly as much effort
finding a specific sort of effect if you’re
running 10 or 15 of it. I’ve also found that
needing less card selection tends to correlate
with a couple other things as well. For one,
decks that rely on and leverage their commander
more aggressively tend to run less card selection,
since they already have their most
important card available. Secondly,
decks that ramp more tend to run less card
selection and more actual factual draw,
since they can generally afford to sink mana into
multiple cards rather than digging around for one
ideal one. Neither of these are set in stone
rules—you’ll have decks that really want to
find specific supporting cards for their powerful
commander, and you’ll also have decks with very
specific ideas of what they want to do once
they’ve ramped up to a lot of mana. These are
just trends to keep in mind when you’re trying
to identify your deck’s needs. With that, let’s
talk about the final question of the video—how
much advantage acquisition should your deck run?
If you’re playing a deck that doesn’t care
as much about selection, focus on ability to
generate mana versus ability to spend mana. If
you’re missing land drops, add lands. If you’re
falling behind in gameplay volume, add ramp.
If you’re finding yourself with excess mana,
add some mana sinks like draw, abilities, or
graveyard themes. If you’re finding yourself with
a lot of cards in hand, try trimming a bit of draw
or orienting your deck more toward mana-efficient
but card-inefficient options like single target
removal, low-cost ramp, and situational parity
breakers. You might think that your first priority
should be the gameplan of your deck, and that does
matter for sure, but for just about every type of
effect you could want to lean toward there will be
versions that are more mana efficient and versions
that are more card efficient, so you can always
be keeping an eye on that balance. Now let’s say
you care more about card selection. For starters,
you’ll want to make sure whatever you’re running
card selection for is being attained—are you able
to filter into key cards? Are you able to find
your situational answers in reasonable lengths
of time? Once this seems to be in a decent
spot, start keeping an eye on how often
you’re able to find your actual factual draw.
Typically actual draw will be, at a minimum,
helpful for finding interaction for what opponents
are doing, particularly if you’re focused on mana
efficient but card inefficient options like
single target removal or counterspells. It
also might be key for getting
more definitively ahead once you
have some amount of setup complete but
don’t yet have control over the game.
As you’ve probably noticed, the point of this
video hasn’t been so much to tell you what is
or isn’t draw, but rather to give you a
framework to work with in analyzing cards
and deciding if they’re what your deck needs. A
lot of times building commander decks is reduced
to following a template, and if a template calls
for X number of draw spells, you’re gonna wanna
know what counts as draw. And, don’t get me wrong,
that sort of approach is a perfectly fine way to
toss together a deck quickly. But take a bit of
extra time to figure out how all the individual
working parts of your deck fit together,
and you’ll have a much stronger end product.
Thanks for watching! And thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. You can find my
decks and their lovely draw suites at the link
down in the description. I’d also like to thank
my Patrons for their support, some of whom are on
screen now. If you want to support this channel,
you can sign up for my Patreon at
the link down in the description.